do you think science should guide what
we consider
queer or or should we should we let that
be a societal and a self
or a self um expression
if we identify this gene is that should
be the only thing that we rely upon
i i think i mean queer is square is such
a moving target
um i mean queer almost queer almost
always needs something
to exist in opposition against um
uh i mean you know queer is um
how do i put it um i mean queer needs a
queer really does need to be
transgressive
um against against a prevailing system i
think i think that what is
the notion of what is queer will change
over time
um and i had
i think you know a identifying
identifying
the the gay gene identifying you know a
distinct
biology uh distinctive marker of
homosexual of queerness or
homosexuality um does not necessarily
confer um confirm all these traits
and this is one thing that one nuance
that has that hasn't come up yet
is that queer is not queer is not
necessarily
gay i mean there are queerness
and the the lgbt lgbt
uh is different than the q in many
respects um
that queerness is queerness is a form of
fluid homosexuality that that really
exists i think
in um in active
active conversation and active
opposition to
a lot of mainstreams and these are these
are some of the traits that i was
meaning to identify
um we have that quickly these these
acquiring not every uh lgbt person
can query the future in the way that
someone who is truly who truly
identifies and embodies
queerness can so i think that's that's
an important distinction
is um really isolating what is
what is queerness what is it now what
what has it been
and can we can we keep that kind of this
non-assimilationist
identity can can we keep that coming
here we preserve that going forward